Прицілитись у ворога…
А, точніше, навчитися цьому.
Так виглядає базовий курс міського бою та поводження зі зброєю для жінок,
який проводять у лісі на околицях Києва.
Анастасія - кінопродюсерка. Вона ніколи раніше не тримала в руках гвинтівку.
Опусти зброю, тримаємо гранату руками.
Тримаємо. Витягнули, кинули, заховалися.
Що я маю сказати?
"Граната" скажіть. Уламки.
Добре, кажіть "уламки".
Оп, заховалися, сіли.
Розумію, що ці навички дуже актуальні.
Ніколи не знаєш, що нас буде чекати далі.
Багато близьких, рідних на фронті.
І я розумію, що якщо… є така вірогідність, що війна затягнеться на роки,
то жінки також можуть бути корисні на фронті.
Анастасія ще не вирішила, чи піде служити.
Але, як і багато інших учасниць цих тренувань, вона хоче принаймні отримати навики.
Син Тетяни воює в ЗСУ. Жінка хоче бути готовою приєднатися до нього.
Ну і взагалі, війна йде - потрібно всім навчатися.
Вміти тримати стрій, стріляти, бути готовими до всього.
Закінчуються бійці, на жаль. Людей, ресурсу мало, тому ми теж маємо бути в строю.
Знявся механічно - порожньо. Далі знімаю запобіжник, відводжу раму.
Уроки поводження з гвинтівкою для жінок проводять волонтери-військові.
Магазин. Очима дивимося в подавач.
Бачите патронник? Де патронник? Покажіть мені.
Патронники, обов'язково дзеркало затвору треба глянути.
Крию.
Йду.
1, 2, 3 - сіли.
Крию.
Пересування, запобіжник. Молодці!
І перевіряють їхні вміння.
Якщо є дерево - за дерево. Ви мали сісти.
А мішенями тут слугують російські політичні та військові керівники.
Шойгу, Кадиров, Пригожин, Z, Москва, V, орк і праворуч Путін заховався.
Інструктори кажуть: добре, що є такий курс лише для жінок.
Їм дає якусь впевненість хіба що те, що вони бачать, що вона не сама така,
не одна, тому, можливо, їм морально легше.
Фізично до всіх однаково ставимося, нікого не відмічаємо.
Відмічаю тільки тоді, коли хтось краще стріляє, ніж старається, або гірше.
Тетяна, окрім того, що сама тренується, також допомагає в організації курсу.
Бачу різні причини, чому кожен тут.
Зараз багато травмованих, багато з міст поприїжджали.
Дівчатка були і під окупацією. Тому дівчат об'єднує це, зближує. Це і як арт-терапія.
Подолати свій страх приходить, хто боїться.
Приміром, як Анна, 26-річна менеджерка з продажу.
Вона хоче приєднатися до бойового підрозділу в армії.
Я поки навчаюся. Тобто перший раз на полігоні мені було…
звичайно, коли ти розумієш, що ти будеш стріляти з бойових, у тебе є така невелика паніка.
Але, в принципі, надалі тут я себе відчуваю спокійно.
Хочу вивчити всі ази і нормально тримати зброю в руках.
В Анни особисті причини піти у військо.
У себе вдома в Києві Анна показує нам фото свого чоловіка Андрія.
Він понад рік тому зник безвісти на передовій.
Її брат також воював і також пропав.
Анна вважає, що вони обидва - у полоні в росіян.
Вона витратила місяці, намагаючись з'ясувати, що з ними сталося.
А тепер сама вирішила стати військовою.
Те, що я хочу вступити в Збройні сили України, дає мені стимул жити і продовжувати щось робити.
Тому що іноді все підкошується, і не хочеться абсолютно нічого.
І я розумію, що якщо я нічого робити не буду, то я просто заляжу, і від цього буде тільки гірше.
А так я зможу добитися чогось там і зрозуміти, як це.
І надія на те, що дізнаюся хоч якусь інформацію.
Анна планує приєднатися до 3-ї окремої штурмової бригади,
де, за її словами, вже є жінки.
За деякими солдатками вона стежить у соціальних мережах.
Звичайно, страшно. Ти думаєш, що от ти підеш туди, а не дай Бог що…
Страшно, що ти будеш пораненим, момент, можливо, якийсь такий настане, що ти не виживеш.
У мене фраза така, вона, можливо, буде банальна,
але я не боюся померти - я боюся не знайти свого чоловіка і брата, звичайно.
Розвідниця Ярина Чорногуз знала, що втратила свого партнера, коли пішла в ЗСУ у 2020 році.
На той час він вже загинув.
Ярина розуміє мотивацію і бажання жінок боротися, тому може дати їм кілька порад.
Спочатку прийміть, що це буде непросто.
Треба прийняти той факт, що як жінка ви збираєтеся влаштуватися на роботу,
яку більшість чоловіків вважає чоловічою.
У вас буде багато перешкод і багато вагань від товаришів і командирів.
Тому будьте спокійними і не зважайте на це.
Вона каже, що жінки, які мають намір служити на передовій,
повинні максимально свідомо робити такий вибір.
Якщо ви готові виконувати ту ж роботу, що й чоловіки,
носити важкі речі на передовій, носити тіла, носити броню, то ви можете піти на бойову позицію.
Якщо ж ні, то краще цього не робити,
тому що тоді більшість чоловіків автоматично вважатимуть,
що всі жінки такі, як ви, і це не добре для прав жінок в армії.
Тут, на тренуванні жінки це усвідомлюють.
Звичайно, буде дуже важко, щоб у тебе все це вийшло.
Тому що у дівчини, в якої немає досвіду і сильного життя,
і яка хоче в штурмовики, - це, звичайно, треба дуже сильно показати себе.
Але рішучість Анни, схоже, непохитна.
Вона має мету і йде до неї.